now this guy has been on the crash
course I think five times in the last
six months so clearly likes the crash
course how you doing man good to see you
bro keep it well yeah man let me see you
man
here we go white oh dude I love that I'm
gonna wear that right now man you want
to see your scooter
[Music]
what do you think I love it man it's
awesome we can maybe walk up to the
center of Litchfield got a nice lunch
talk business property this guy has been
to the crash course what four five times
four times in the last what six months
yeah pretty much every crash course that
we have and what you always sits on the
very very front row so uh I have five
copies of all your books I love that man
[Music]
what are you thinking that I think
long-term I think it would only make
sense to do bigger deals and like the
castle is actually like what's really
got me excited well you like buy it for
like you put it on okay innit spend two
million and then it's worth 6 million
off and then I'll rent it out and
refinance yeah well what should your
seller keep it I don't want to keep it
really no because but now I have when I
have a finished product it's like that I
just think what I if I'm gonna if I'm
gonna keep it and we finance it would I
buy as it is yeah there's no way I'd buy
the castle for 6 million yeah and rent
it out a bit terrible buy to that so
what would I keep it yeah I bet off to
sell it in the morning I'm not you have
to put that into bear so what do you
think is the best type of property to
just keep long term let's say I give you
100 million pounds cash of 100 million
100 million merchant right commercial
yeah you wouldn't buy a thousand houses
no no never never
I've already felt like I've got enough
houses even though the return on
investment is probably a little bit
better certainly on paper yeah
definitely on paper and the Cape's
depreciation is probably a bit goes up
quicker yeah with residential you grow
important people to manage because the
things happen yeah you know yeah you
know 100 yeah
no 100 no like so maybe like 10 20 30
hey Charles yeah yeah and then and then
do bigger stuff yeah well you could do
that if you wanted to start off with you
can build a residential property but the
thing the only thing is if you're
thinking super super long term and you
know you're going to go crazy and you
can succeed like crazy in this yeah what
you'll probably end up doing is you
might get 20 HMOs and then you'll go
into big deals but then you'll end up
selling your HMOs
to put it into big deals anyway yeah so
you could say what I just start straight
where I mean to go on the flip side to
that is the experience that you'd get
from starting with the small deals would
probably serve you well it would help
with your story and your branding
because you can show all these
that you've done I'm saying so I mean
sometimes I think you know I said the
crash course you've got to do what you
say if you think hot just what you
feeling you get sometimes yeah hey
that's great yeah the the soda thing is
for me and these guys thanks thank you
it's a great note saying here so much
I'm actually I'm moving to I've lived in
Litchfield for yeah I'm moving to a move
to London tomorrow so I'm enjoying my
last time which field thanks so much
yeah convicted information have you
heard them I'm trying to figure out what
the best long-term property is to keep
because the thing that scared me is like
what I heard
Dean gracioso you say I have two
thousand two hundred and fifty family
homes yeah cash flowing 1.5 million
dollars a month a month yeah another
indie otherwise hi the Allah is high but
it's so much hassle to manage so I'm
like and he's sending off now like I
mean he he got thirty percent only an F
so he's selling all of them off Wow
entering only multi-family so I'm just
thinking like if I was to get a thousand
houses you won't get that one mistake
exactly absolutely right get one man
block sure one a thousand houses do I
try really what do I want to have like
ten and then just do only big deals big
deals you have one address scale yeah
yeah all right maybe but half like it's
more scalable I mean mmm one other thing
you could do you don't know for sure how
easy it's going to be to raise finance
and stuff yeah it could be really easy
it could be harder
you could start with the smaller deals
right spot and see how easy is to raise
funds for the smaller deals and if
you're like wow I can raise finance easy
peasy I can just get all this thing then
then at that point
sorry all right I'm gonna move on to
some and work your way up yeah
because I know another thing is this
you're always make mistakes on your
first deals
simple you rather make mistakes aren't
100 grand house or a three million pound
building yeah yeah so make all the
mistakes
early on and get the learning CNX 12
months is right in 12 months time I want
to be I want to have a hundred thousand
subscribers on my property YouTube
channel I want to be able to demonstrate
that I now to raise finance now when
I've done that I've had this one of my
solicitors my power team set up to do
that I want to have ten hang Chennault's
you to hate you most not single that's
potentially but whatever
yeah and small overage that Terra's
dental bills yeah and then I want it in
a year's time worth 100,000 subs when my
ten houses or 20 or whatever am i
following with my power team we might
experience on my knowledge now I'm gonna
go and do my first big castle no Jackie
Minnie cast I can't work yeah I could
work yeah and then take the money and
then do more development with it or
every what do you think is the ultimate
property type to keep long-term the
ultimate I told you all under yeah
warehouses kam University student blocks
rents them out to universities I mean
can't go wrong with that stuff yeah yeah
I mean and you know it's just totally
passive yeah yeah so what do you think
is the entry-level to like one student
thing like a million or in equity
Morton but so more more than own equity
yeah but your morning pick-me-up maybe a
million million yeah yeah but then you
can do some more you can do like you
could buy a Starbucks the place yeah it
depends where it is maybe a few hundred
thousand yeah yeah one of the things I
got in the crash caused to talk about
lease options how to like do lease
options I was just thinking what would
happen if like for the full day yeah I
will just call up people and do this and
and then just view them or you can get a
v8 you have the list for me and then so
what would happen can you like get 10
lease options per month or was it like
Coach K yeah I mean when when we did the
eviction I sent my guys out I saw them
out three days and I got a lot seven
lease options in three
so what so why won't you do this like
for like the whole time like every day
because most people don't don't offer I
love that I just go like I see something
it works and I just like keep doing it
yeah
so I see like wow like these guys did
the training with you and they did this
so I'm gonna do this like every day
because in your mind so though you're
the way you're wired is you're you're a
scaler you're a big thinker yeah
most people get 10 H of those they're
making 5 grand a month and then they're
like ah that worked well what what why
do you want 100 yeah what and you're
you're you're making 20 grand a month
right
yeah you got 4 or 500 grand you could
put that into property really well earn
a full time living all that make 5 10
grand a month
yes of income and then just relax and
live happily ever after
yeah but that's not the way you think
yeah but most people do yeah makes sense
makes sense so what would most people
want to go and get 100 houses or so but
in my case would it make sense to do
like all these nice options I just rent
them out as a single letter here
tomorrow probably not now well no
because what's your end goal I think
well what's the end goal event like 10
years what's the end game go ankle is a
million pound equity okay yeah why why I
made panaqua - yeah mate that's a
terrible end goal you can do that in six
months a billion pollen equity a billion
planet yeah okay but it might make you a
billionaire yeah why to be honest I just
I think like if you can do something I
think you do something to get you there
yeah sure do around speaking to people
in Sunderland that can't sell the house
for 60 grand because they're a negative
equity and you go that he's not going to
get you anywhere in the air to your
billionaire goal yeah so I don't see
that that would that would that's not
going to serve you
yeah that's great for someone who's
desperate to get their foot on the
they're not want any money yeah that's
great but it's something about you're a
billionaire but if you can get like
let's say two lease options per week
yeah you get a hundred houses in one
year right 100 houses that are worth 50
grand that you own you have no equity in
them
I'm just getting a few in Japan if you
want for cash flow and then you wait to
go see something make your billionaire
yeah
sniffing heavy never gonna get a bit
younger yeah it's not it's not big
enough it's too small yeah yeah I mean
if you wanted to go speak to some
commercial people in London they've got
some big units and stuff and secure
their own lease option agreement maybe
yeah it has a different beast shot man
mm-hmm
so I was getting ready to service
accommodations and lease option
agreement plus gray for nine percent of
my students but it's nothing about
anyone billing there mm-hmm
I want to be a billionaire that's where
I'm going I think you will definitely
get there way before grant he don't give
his stock property and she like 30 he's
a lot closer than I earn now though he's
uh he's I don't know how much I'm worth
I'm probably worth about 15 20 million
yeah in equity in equity yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's worth about 300
yeah but he's older than I am
yeah WH pretty much every time I leave I
got a mentor I've always succeeded then
within it within a year or two and now
he's mentor in May so who knows yeah but
in the past I've always overtook my
mentors and I have to find a new mentor
yeah you know maybe you're over ten men
hopefully because that's that's that
should be every every trainers desire
yeah is that their students and go into
the sky yeah you know so yeah I'll just
be looking at big stuff big stuff yeah
so for the first 12 months what do you
think should I do pretty much always
with you yeah what's the biggest
investment in yourself yeah
and that would also Intel your brand the
reason I'm so wealthy is because I've
got such a good brand
yeah so if I was you in the first year
I'd only be doing stuff with the sole
intention of your brand
mm-hmm probably mhm that make sense yeah
so makes all do a deal just for the sake
you do the deal because I know it'd be a
great story
mm-hm yeah and I admittedly care about
the house but I just to show that you
can do it no no it blow up on YouTube
yeah it's just a legit deal it's a great
deal yeah but in my mind is it really
worth the hassle
well I just missed 1 missile oh I don't
just dump it into commercials yeah but I
know that it will get the story
mm-hm which will then get the audience
hmm which will then get the money yeah
makes sense soured focus on my youtube
channel yes and to maybe like 10 20 by
refurbish refinance properties HMOs
don't mix it up a little bit
uh-huh so you can you can say right what
property do you want me to sit do what
deal would you want to see me do uh-huh
I wanna see you do what hey all right
Oh document here go and do HMO buy it
yeah document it show you guys what
those what they wanted to say Wow
amazing watch are the next let them
decide mm-hmm yeah
he's good to you were you're putting
yourself out there and you're saying
right guys I am gonna be a property
guinea pig almost like for a year for a
year
I'm just gonna test different stuff and
I'm gonna document it and I'm going to
show you and by the end of the year
you'll be able to see what the truly
best strategy is at the moment there's
lease options rent two rents be are our
HMOs all these different abbreviations
and terms is London good is that north
good so I'm just going to try it with
them mm-hm
but don't do it none of it is gonna make
you a billionaire you
what's gonna rate your billionaire is
the brand that you'll have by the end of
the year and then from that brand joint
venturing with people and attracting
people to go and do big deals yeah yeah
but so it's like a stepping stone yeah
yeah that makes sense so basically I
work on my brand and my youtube channel
yeah and then that way what you're
really trying to gauge you get an
audience yeah and then you're trying to
get followers what's up listen if I want
to borrow a million pounds tomorrow I
can buy it tomorrow because I've got
finance guys that trust me and know who
I am if I want to do a joint venture if
I want to if I want to invest in London
or if I want it like I went to an
auction last week a London auction every
one of yours you know I just got to
there's the auction they all knew you
all was yeah people coach me oh my gosh
hey coatsy yeah when you've got that
kind of influence mm-hmm you know yeah
and this advice I wouldn't say so
everybody I'm saying it to you because I
know that this is your thing you're a
youtuber yeah get people's attention
you're good at building up a following
and there's a lot of money in that
that's what going to our donors yeah so
what do you think should be like the
first like I sort of wanna set it
challenge for the first year make a
public challenge were say but the end of
next year I want to accomplish this yeah
and then and then it draws everyone in
because they want to see or how am i
doing you know what I mean and then it
creates urgency for me to do stuff would
you regret that you say obviously for me
to reach my target by a certain time
limit so I would start maybe you don't
need that you don't need you don't need
accountability man like you're good yeah
you don't need you don't need I think
you might be better off to every odd I
think what you might better off to do
instead of that potentially is to over
the year try and do every strategy
mm-hmm so to say right I'm gonna I'm
gonna do a lease option I'm gonna HM I'm
gonna do this this and little strategies
and then ask people what do you want to
see next
mm-hmm and then go and do it okay and
then do it and do it as fast as you can
and then you can like you can vlog it
and you can have like a little time or
something you know day 1 day 2 day 3 and
the challenge can be how fast can you do
it
yeah half asking you it mm-hmm yeah I
want to do a buy refurbish refinance
deal
that's that takes time man you've got
got to find the dude you've got to put
the money down you think I can wait to
complete you they know original you
should I beg cash or get ready - yeah
kiss bye - it's quicker uh-huh yeah but
when you do that though the authority
that you're build because people were
like this guy knows his stuff
and by the end of the year he's like
you've done every strategy yeah I mean
yeah so a potentially mm-hmm
on the property side what would me if
you want to be a billionaire what do you
see yourself doing in like ten years
time what's the dream lifestyle the
dream lifestyle would be to do that's a
long question like ten years I mean just
three years ago I would never would have
thought that I do this here now what I'm
doing now
so I would see myself doing YouTube
videos mmm doing also events I just love
meeting who it's like I'm doing events
all the time not for scootering like for
kids and stuff parents yeah you do this
for property so like like you literally
do exactly what I do
mmm except for property I sell t-shirts
and merge you sell calls and training
and so I were to do that brand myself
make youtube videos and then just like I
just love making content like inspiring
people if you said the best way to help
people is to show them what's possible
yeah especially our young people I see
like all my friends I'm like why don't
you like go to Simon's crash course and
learn this and do this like
yeah so how do you reckon I'm not bad to
hell with that stuff I think the way the
biggest way you could make a difference
to me would be to give me like a
specific clear vision like what I should
you just tell me like what and like I do
it hmm
just tell me hey to 20 houses buy them
cash do this find them get a personal
assistant or get this or that and then
there's a clear vision for that and then
I would document it and then also fun
what happen is when you documenting it
that people help you so if you say right
next Chung is I will get a lease option
agreement and you've log in it and you
struggle in our conscious guys people
messaging but I'll try this area I've
got this lead I've got this yeah and you
it's like easy man you get anything you
want
yeah I'm gonna struggle of course I'm
not gonna struggle like it's not
difficult uh-huh but but most people
would never do that because it's
bullseye lecture vlog it and stuff you
think because then but most people were
thinking but what happens if I don't get
it it's embarrassing after three weeks
on that's good like when you feel like
they even more like say ah
Claudius you got this like that makes
them want to support you even yeah I'd
say oh sorry the deal fell through hey
you got this Internet even in America
it's like when you fail yeah when you
win like everyone shares in it but when
you fail they like if you want to
support you wanna do it man I just
stopped blogging it straight away I just
like even today right here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna I'm gonna this year
I'm gonna do as many deals as I can just
as many times again any strategies as I
can okay I love that so this year I'm
gonna do as many deals as I can and as
many strategies as I can well on the
Academy yeah even like a renter NGO you
up yeah I do a right to hate you know
and I'll do a right to serviced
accommodation are compared to see what's
best
uh-huh and then you can compare the
deals and just lock the whole thing mate
you'll blow up yeah that's good
that's good I love that because in my
opinion it's like whether I said my golf
let's say get 10 houses
yeah or 20 it would or just five like
cuz I could be same effort for me but if
you say I'm gonna get as many deals as I
can you know they make these strategies
as I can there's no limit that yeah
exactly setting yourself up to fail or
you know setting it too easy depends on
the size of the deal so you could get
you could get 20 deals but you're not
making much money well you got six and
you can making a lot of money yeah
domain so you see you wouldn't set like
a a number times off like no not even
like equity or cash flow just not as
many as possible I just say I'll be like
right this year uh-huh Oh over these
next 12 months my challenge is to do as
many deals as I can using as many
different strategies as I can and by the
end of the year I'll be able to tell you
which ones were the best that's it uncle
your thing mm-hm and then people are
gonna be that straight away they'll be
like do this do you still do this cuz
they'll be thinking the deals that they
want to do but they're a bit hmm don't
say Claudius can you go try out for me
mm-hmm yeah or if they're thinking eyes
Liverpool good try Liverpool Claudius
and then you're gonna do it if it
doesn't work it matter
mhm and you're ready to skate no I
didn't actually pay as much money as I
thought
so the learning point is stay away from
Liverpool HMS yeah do not how much do
you think it matters where the
properties are like wait a second one
Liverpool one Manchester one in grand
leads Greg awesome it's okay to have
like letting agent hear hear hear it
versus just one patch we're letting
agent if I'm advising you and you're not
vlogging I would say choose a patch and
stick with that area it's easier but if
you're vlogging the 12 I'm sure you all
remember the purpose of this the purpose
of the properties are not to make money
I have to make money for the actual
purpose but the actual purpose is to
grow a massive YouTube following
yeah to grow us of YouTube following you
want everywhere because then people in
that town will be late yeah you got all
got my patch in its sole furred
Manchester people go I live in Salford
yeah but but then if you do another one
in Salford and then another one it's
awful another was awful it's not only
won't ever pull all you can't do that in
Liverpool yeah and then you go I'm gonna
try it yeah and then you go right I'm
going to London to do a red dress in
London let's say you can't do it I can
well let's say you hobble you actually
know it's really tough yeah great and
you probably want about 80% wins
and about 20% fails mm-hmm you don't to
keep failing cuz I mean it's like oh
jeez
yeah it's uninspiring but I don't want
to fail on purpose like it will the
failures know behind work well yeah you
will file yeah and you want to just
embrace the failure yeah that's good so
the goal is not to just buy houses
houses houses because that's never gonna
get me to a merely a billion yeah so
just just getting as many deals as
possible as possible yeah in as many
different cities as possible to vlog
everything to have as many followers as
possible to then be like right now I
wanna be a billionaire how do I do it
and by that point you'll have the
experience you have the brand yeah we
have the team yeah they're the access to
finance to go make that happen
yeah so would you actually use my big
channel I already have and make the
videos there I mean if you would be like
very low initially because no one is
like call us what are you uploading up
are the the the problem with that is
you'll probably lose a lot of your
current followers yeah because they're
not interested in property yeah and then
just below I wanna watch I wanna watch
skewers and that's unsubscribe the
advantage of course would be you start
with a big platform but it's a different
audience where your photos currently
where they're based I would say for 40%
UK 40% America or 30% America and then
10% Germany Spain and 10% where were you
born
Germany okay so you German blood and the
owner you lived in Los Angeles no I've
been I've been living in the UK for like
four years or I came into 15 here from
from Germany yeah oh cool okay so
so what we're just saying yeah you
channel chairman I mean audience you're
gonna kill your channel man if you if
you do property on that channel I think
I mean it's a pure channel you mean I'll
do a self yeah and then I can still
shower out my other channels I guess if
you interest it yeah it's just subscribe
there yeah and then those who will
naturally go there yes we're just
forcing and hey look yeah just annoy
them instead you want to carry on doing
your scooter world right yeah so you
want to mix I would mix awesome like
seconds are so different it's such a
different thing I'll be very careful of
that okay like if it like me if I
started putting it on my youtube channel
if I something started doing health
videos
my guys would be like they can keep
getting notified or they're not
interested domain yeah I'd be really
careful man
yeah how old are your followers between
13 and 25 is the is the is the age is
like 60% and then like 40% is like 35 to
55 represent 30% one-third so every
third person it's like adult is beyond
30 years old okay and other mostly men
or women oh it's a 70 percent male 30%
female so every third is a female all
right okay boy I'm age is 21 to 35 and
I've got 90 percent male yeah male yeah
so that's it then man 12 months I'll go
do those mini strategies I'm gonna do as
many deals in as many different seas and
then at the end of the air they'll tell
you what's best your question that you
had tonight which is what's the best you
want to almost be able to answer that
yourself but in residential mm-hmm
Darian yeah like its own bias yeah up
today currents were relevant property
channel but then but then after 12
months you wouldn't just keep buying
houses in Haiti more you were then like
the end goal is always bigger deals what
do you say that ya know because after
twelve months is what you'll do your
side
alright here's the thing like after 12
months you say guys and then went to
rents of the lease options I'm doing
HMOs I've been single that something boy
refurbished refinance or doing a little
bit development hangers are there all
these different deals yeah and they've
all been great my favorite has probably
been the barber 30 finalists now I feel
now I've got the contacts and experience
to do much bigger stuff so my next deal
is gonna be a castle
yeah boom blow up then three months
later guys I've done it it's been really
profitable I've done the castle people
already know you're at you're an
experienced property investor at this
point to a point you've owned the castle
now it's guys if you want to invest
together with me I'm looking to doing
some big commercial projects put your
details in below one of my team will
give you a call
mmm yeah and then you two is gonna be a
case of raising finance to put into
bigger deals yeah and potentially
partnering on the if you want to work as
like an affiliate or whatever it would
look like with the Train and stuff
mm-hmm I know you're mad out of a cup
for the crash courses and the training
and stuff yeah but we could work we can
work something out there as well if
that's you be interested in yeah I think
I just think about so I think the
biggest shift he just gave me Samuel is
rather than thinking about how many
houses like what do I buy it's like
because that's never going to get me to
a billion like never just buying all
these hundreds of houses like in
different cities so now I just told me
to just focus on as many deals as many
different strategies and just build my
audience and brand yeah and then once I
got the base I got I know how to do
renter end and people come here call
this what would see okay so hey
brought us through this this this but
then I have to brand and then I can do
the big deal because that's the goal the
goal is not to have hundreds of houses
yeah yeah I mean even for you like you
just said you're gonna give like more
than 100 houses or you don't want it
like I don't want any more houses yeah
I've heard people see bragging about how
their and a thousand houses and stuff
but all their dear is that ended up just
selling them off and dumping them into
bigger deals anyway I could buy a
thousand houses I could do that spot
like fifty thousand pound
of North by a thousand oh yeah yeah it's
a head like so how many houses do you
think what's your long-term just for
yourself to keep houses yeah
I'd hate you more second single more
that I wouldn't want I wouldn't want to
go into like triple figures like 100
yeah max like fifty hundred yeah like
what I dunno yeah yeah it's like 20
singer let's 20h yours if I wouldn't
even what I would even think about it
just if you do as many as you can in a
year yeah in a year's time you're not
going to have five hundred houses it's
just not gonna happen
yeah cuz you've only got half a million
to play with so I would just do as many
as you possibly can with the intention
being that after a year you're going to
not do residential anymore mm-hmm
there's many as you can yeah you got a
thousand it's not a problem you can take
half million pound turn into a thousand
residential houses that's a blessing not
curse yeah it's okay yeah house okay
yeah you know yeah
so with that money that you've got I
want to get as many deals as possible
don't be wrong some people have 500
houses and they're happy yeah but long
term I don't want to go yeah yeah yeah
yeah and by the time I will already have
the experience and know like what sort
of fuels I like better yeah yeah yeah
so would you so so so worried sure that
should I move um after Tory think like
after what after tour like mid-september
is that when you finish your - yeah okay
so what's your question - a little bit
where should I move okay yeah what are
you not what it you're not sitting
anywhere why don't you just travel
around the country doing deals for a
year
keep Mutants move around yeah sort of
Manchester area because I've met Chester
Liverpool - yeah yeah it's great but I
wouldn't commit til I won because you
know the idea is you want to do as many
deals with the many strategies in as
many areas yeah I'm saying so but yeah -
good nice good so I'm doing all these
deals mainly for to build my audience
now primarily
yeah completely is there any like
certain challenge you would set like a
figure or number or just say as many
Joseph Mehmet
yeah yeah as many okay a little bit
guessing how many you'll do that
yeah or I can you'll get 250 deal or I
can you'll get to ten and it's just
because you don't know man
pens I'm deal pivot sometimes things
like long to go ahead anyway yeah so you
don't know how many you're gonna be able
to do but the challenges in 12 months
and rude many as I can
yeah it's like when you play football
you don't side on the score three goals
you say I got not in the nets to score
any goals as I can let's see and that's
part of the fun happy I'm gonna get to
would you what do you say suggest me
getting like a virtual assistant to like
do lists of deals or like outsource the
viewing as well like yoga spa you can
have people probably flocking to try and
help yeah yeah
you know man yeah so when people come
and approach it all can I help or can I
just say yeah man come on working for
free yeah don't wanna okay Howard brand
and then what you get like also personal
assistant to like to admin tasks if you
need it yeah yeah but when you when you
need it then you've got one uh-huh yeah
sure okay so for the pirate because I
don't want to like but just buy houses
and I have my cash stuck in yes I want
to get them like below market without
you refurbish add value want to do to
buy as many deals in as many areas we're
using as many strategies in 12 months
uh-huh that's that's it that's the goal
that's the goal and then you focus
things at the moment you're thinking oh
I don't leave my money into oh I don't
know everyone there's one new big I
don't know if I should do I don't get
too many houses that no no you could too
confused yeah they've had all these
different pieces advise and you need
you'll think you need to be your niche
yeah yeah which is just as many houses
in there's many areas using as many
strategies as possible yeah so if
there's a deer and you think all that's
going to be a real swole over and it's
gonna take me two years it's got a
toddler than most women it's going to
affect my vision of that's a mission
statement that could be on your youtube
banner glorious property investor or
property entrepreneur
twelve-month challenge devised to get as
many yeah let me take some notes you
know I'm saying that yeah that's your
thing yeah so I should name my channel
like Claudius Pratesi property journey
Claudia's property entrepreneur property
entrepreneur yeah because that's what
you are isn't an entrepreneur but the
channel name like property journey know
your name
just Claudius Pratesi property
entrepreneur you definitely want because
you are the brand yeah so you don't want
to channel anything other than you but I
know you've already got your name it's
just my name yeah so the second channel
would be Cloris Pratesi property
entrepreneur yeah yeah or investor
property investor ah well if you're
doing rent to rents and deal packaging
and raising final a that's not
investment is that small that's like
entrepreneur more you're more of an
entrepreneur uh-huh doing yeah yeah and
you of your you're a businessman you've
got a brand and a word and then you
would do just as many videos like
whenever it comes up like just don't
create any content just document yeah
just document everything document
everything and rather than a secretary
if anything I'd get a videographer I
already have one in my videos okay yeah
this follow you around and stuff yeah
yeah great fine but they be able to
probably do the property stuff as well
yeah probably
rocks yeah but you move move in with me
and just film everything everything
everything in editing yeah ok ok I like
nothing I like that I like that like
like write blog then tune Ben yeah hi
Ben ok document everything and upload it
and then for Instagram also like just
yeah yeah ok document everything as many
deals and as many strategies as possible
yeah
any area any area I know you know even
any area you want as many property deals
huh in as many areas using as many
different strategies as possible within
12 months okay I like that except for I
think if I just go mainly Birmingham
upward so get the area a bit then so
just forget the area just as many
property deals using as many yeah
strategies as possible within a year how
many do you think I'll do and what deal
do you want to see next
okay you know I'm saying it's possible
boom that's that's the mission the
mission is going to my channel do as
many property deals using as many
strategies as possible in in 12 months
yeah in 12 months okay and then I say
and then they comment and what Gerry Wow
yeah and then you just go ahead this
yeah I like that okay and then when you
go out to do it you'll need help
first when your contacts like me and my
team we're on the Academy because you're
gonna like if someone says I'll go and
do it ready to man you've got old man I
need new contracts I need this I need
yeah and then we've got you back on that
yeah okay and also the more like as well
if these videos if they like if your
videos reference me then I'm gonna be
incentivize to push them out yeah dude
I'm saying
so should actually also say hey I'm
doing you know I'm training with Samuel
and I mean it's up to you I'm not
telling you what to say yeah okay but if
you do that then I'm gonna be
incentivized to be like wow that's like
an a free advert yeah it is like if
you're traveling the world doing deals
off the back of the Academy that's like
a walking talking testimonial for me
yeah it is which is then gonna
incentivize me to promote and push that
out there as well mm-hm
so yeah I mean and also like if they
know that I have professional training
yeah like they will I'm not just a guy
just doing some deals and
have your training so professional
training so yeah so big it doesn't think
you're a lunatic you're like you backed
up yeah yeah yeah but there's an advert
for me
yeah which is then like makes me
invested in it because if you I mean you
I'm not telling you what to say but if
you're doing it if you're doing it op
totally you know and it you're not
mentioning the academy and myself and
all that I'll be like awesome man
good job if you're doing it and you're
pointing people to me I was like wow
this guy and then more invested in it
that make sense yeah so of course that's
awesome so actually it's almost like a
12 month like race so like I'm gonna get
like an apartment or something yeah in
Manchester have my videographer move in
and just everyday like wake up do calls
book viewings do deals yeah it's a
twelve of rice it's also a twelve of
people will see it's like a 12 man
experiment yeah because you're saying
right I'm gonna invest my life alongside
my business but I don't know invest my a
big portion of my life into property
let's see what happens let's see if this
really works
mm-hmm of course you know that it well
but like from the audience point of view
for all they know you could after three
months it's like I just doesn't work
don't they don't know that so they're
gonna be excited yeah you know you get
your first deal and I'm happy to be in
it like you know you can like you can
phone me we can do Skype calls and stuff
but if you get stuck in committee I've
got this issue I wonder what my mental
thinks yeah and it especially if you
paid a lot of views if you're getting 20
views and stuff I'm gonna talk a lot but
if I know you've got a lot of views I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be like dude I want
to be in this yeah it's like a two-way
it's like yeah you know yeah yeah I know
I mean boss I think it's specially like
if you film it like it so if you don't
film it it's almost like like secret
like no one like I just have the desire
to like show everyone like hey I'm doing
this right yeah yeah that's good because
you're in your and inspire mm-hm
you like inspiring people you like
helping people you got high energy you
like being on
you know so you're just making the most
off of what the skills you were born
with what's your name hi George
nice to meet you where you from Tamworth
nice you watch my videos oh that's
awesome
Oh a nice do you want take a picture
let's do it yeah yeah awesome
nice to meet you man nice to meet you
awesome see that guys no I think I think
YouTube is like because cuz 400k it's
not gonna get me to a billion not even
close its that's so the 400k it's just
pretty much nothing it's just right it's
just all a brand my my yeah yeah just
build my brand and then what's gonna
really get me there is the knowledge I
got from that experience food porn lay
the contact the context wins yeah - then
get you millions and then tens of
millions and yes yeah yeah that makes
sense okay city here's the plan
twelve months to it as many deals and
with as many strategies as possible yeah
to build your audience
mmm-hmm - then do a big deal in front of
your audience which is your crown jewel
mm-hmm your crown jewel more than below
up but then it will also show people
what kind of deals you're now worthy of
and then you're going to start your
adventuring with people on more crown
jewels on the crown jewel will then
become the bread and butter yeah they're
the one I will keep doing and stuff yeah
yeah yeah that makes sense that totally
makes sense but like Pete before we came
together here I was thinking like okay
how do I use this phone okay like how
old you like recycle recycler cycle but
it's like that's gonna take like forever
to just open my own money yeah yeah yeah
so that's I can wait bigger vision like
build your brand and then just you're
known for property exactly man exactly
and then and then and then just do joint
ventures all day long joint ventures
yeah and then you can come in like if
you want to at that point I'll probably
be able to get some stages and stuff for
you but if you wanted
yeah if you wanted to come and like
share and get in front of people so you
have forgot for me to raise to get to
getting audience together okay regarding
like team and leveraging time do you
think it would make sense to like let's
say get a virtual assistant to like do
list
I mean deal lists scraps for me like
where I basically film like recall - a
deal yeah and they just send me like a
list and then I just call them and then
or can I get like a survey or someone to
like view them for me and I just send
them a list hey please view them for me
with this checklist that I get from the
dfv and yes I so down the line it will
be a become a problem because you'll
behave you have so many properties to
view you have time you'll have so many
addresses to find you have time at that
point you might need a viewer you might
need a PA or whatever the moment you
haven't got that problem so oh I
wouldn't just move myself around do
yourself yeah and then when you think
man I can't physically do this then get
the employ someone yeah
and ask ask ask the audience you know
guys I'm thinking of employing someone
wouldn't you reckon let them yes I'd
your life yeah everything yeah down to
what strategies where should you employ
someone even down to potentially
whereabouts should you get your own
apartment yeah you ask me ask that so
shows like hey guys what do you want to
see like yeah but not just what do you
want to see but what do you think's best
yielding his place my outcome what would
you advise me to do and then what most
people say just go ahead and do it
mm-hmm because some of the people that
we're following you that they know
they're not stupid they know about
property that would advise you yeah so
the goal is as many property deals using
as many strategies as possible in 12
months and then to be able to assess
which one was the best and why yeah and
then one assess so the goal distress
says what the best strategy is yes and
why did you is that ones always asking
this like what's the best strategy hey
and then you can be like this is what I
think was the best yeah my favorite deal
was that hm
I did in Manchester and then it's like
okay people like that yeah
and the goal is to build my audience
then do a big deal
that's my crown jewel and then joint
ventures album at yeah at the end of the
year once I've done all these deals once
I found out the best day I'm going to do
a big crown jewel I'm gonna crank it up
and do a big deal yeah that would be
like your castle now pretty much yeah
yeah like the castle for me is not my
crown jewel is you're writing all your
conjure yeah yeah I mean there's other
things going on as well that big but
that one's like that one's just been the
most impressive it's the most yeah I
thinking and then on the way I can I
think I think what's gonna happen is
first a lot of people will say oh
Claudius why do you do property now I
mean like you discutir
so they will many will just keep
watching
and then many will say oh no I just want
to watch the scooter videos but there's
going to be this confusion but I'm very
transparent right I say hey you know I'm
interested in property I'm gonna do this
now document everything and and then
people will I think long term people who
want to watch property will just watch
me and they will come to me I mean even
I get messages all the time on my
Instagram about hey I see you at the
Samuel crash course or like my and they
go like or like they go be either say I
saw you there or they say oh where did
you go Yeah right and it's like oh yeah
I know into semo's crash course editor
and then like just of a crash course
like people go oh you're the guy always
on stage oh you're the guy like yeah
yeah yeah listening like yeah there we
go so you're already starting you're
building your brand just by coming to
the events yeah and the more you do that
every time you're an event but when
you're at the DFA I'll be like filming
it see how so you should advise me to
just get because with the money I mean I
could just right now by find 20 all
right 10 single at houses
no one does not know what so I'm gonna
help you so I'm gonna get you to a
billionaire yeah same as if you put that
400 grand into a big way
how cemented it down to Amazon so gonna
help ya because then what you can't eat
you're out and money then you then got
work more and get more money and then
put it in and just keep going you want
it you want to make that with that fall
under ground you want to make such a
splash such a noise with it
uh-huh yeah that makes sense yeah okay
let me see I got actually a few
questions written down actually it's fun
man you go ahead is that is that helpful
advice that's very helpful
has it changed the whole thinking yeah
and it wasn't clarity as well yeah
because before was like oh I got this
phone okay like how do i what do i do
versus hey look like if you want to get
to a billion like you need a brand yeah
of course
you know Brattain to be known for you
are the guy doing deals experts I mean
if I look at you people go like all
Samuel he can just be anywhere you can
take everything away you can just do
deals just from your knowledge yeah and
they go like property Samuel II it's
right it's a crank I don't want to be
the one number one person yeah and then
people must you get hate he invest for
me or with me
but I don't really do that you don't do
that yeah but you want to do that yeah
that's that's the thinking behind it yes
the end wanna grow a massive portfolio
yeah yeah okay so you personally what do
you think would be the most realistic
target I could get to other than you
want to target no target as I say it's
like when you're playing football how
many goals can you score as many as
possible
yeah the football team don't go right
okay so we're trying score three goals
no it's gonna just keep going going as
many as possible yeah if I can get ten
goals is good yeah I'll just keep going
right yeah and the next question was
which you pretty much answer this what's
the ultimate property type to own for
the long-term let's say
Samuel here's 100 million pound cash
yeah you will just diversify to not be
commercial commercial yeah yeah big
commercial units and stuff
units yeah yeah yeah so the goal is
commercial and then but now you haven't
got that money
you haven't got 100 million no you were
back
to it I have access to the any yeah yeah
house you've got your brand from the 400
right yeah yeah yeah so what are what
are the main tasks I need to do like
from morning tonight do you think it's
set on a YouTube channel uh-huh shoot a
video okay use some of this footage if
you want okay and just tell everyone
what you're doing got a right move make
us not tell everyone what you're doing
yeah be the first thing I'll be like
turn on my youtube channel doing a video
this is what I'm doing what do you think
my very first step should be and get
some comments coming in that'll be the
very first day yeah because if you were
gonna make calls now you've missed it
yet no one saw it exactly I want a
document from like zero zero or hey guys
now I'm setting up my company or even
before that like now I'm driving back
from Litchfield just like straight or
yeah
setting up my cut everything needs to be
done yeah yeah everything yeah right I
probably employ and another videographer
maybe yeah so they should be with with
me like when it was over 20 foot are
they go unless you're pissing or
sleeping they're filming yeah yeah just
everything but but then but then when I
do my deals like I need to be mainly on
Rightmove super Gumtree and book views
and calls yeah but you'll mostly be out
on the road viewing house is talking
with people yeah that makes sense
is there any way like you systemize
let's say on Rightmove the people you
already called so you don't call them
backs and again and again then you can
put notes yeah yeah what you can have a
you can register an account on Rightmove
and you can put notes yeah yeah but when
you click on it it will say already
called or whatever yeah okay I can write
an India okay and then how many viewings
per week or how many offers per week man
as you can like as many right yeah what
if I run off money in like five months
and have then your have been bought if
you spent four hundred grand in five
months you already have the following to
then raise more money it doesn't matter
yeah yeah I know then you will yeah
don't worry about that
and then bisa and then the next two
things is when would you recommend me to
get a VA to leverage my time or when you
when you have are so friggin busy that
you physically cannot do what you're
doing yeah right now you want to be
really busy I want to yeah so why do you
thinking on when I'm going to no no no
you want you you want to be busy yeah
last thing you need right now is a
personal assistant and a surveyor
because then it's like you've got
nothing to film yeah yeah no I love that
no that's good and then what would you
say Samuel what does it take to be
successful in property what are the key
attributes or attitude you to have ask
for help
always get a second and a third opinion
so you want to take action fast but
don't buy anything or spend any money or
invest in anything without having good
good professional counsel yeah so when
let's say I find a good deal would you
always make the offer first and then get
the surveyor yeah but didn't yeah before
yeah yeah yeah yeah but you know should
one from auction way where you want to
get the survey before offer but because
if you offer you can pull out yeah so
you're gonna offer subject to a survey
and the relevant things yeah how do you
think could I get let's say a builder or
like an expert to view it with me so
that they could already tell me on or
this house will take tons of
refurbishment work and cost so much
money then it might not be even me
putting in the offer like worth doing
this or so ask the estate agent what
they think yeah and then they don't give
you an idea if it needs work them ago I
think it needs about 15 grand and you're
okay we'll look I can offer X on the
basis that it works about 15 grand but
of course I'll need to get a survey in
buildin stuff like that then now put the
offer forward and if they say yes then
you get a build over a survey and if
it's going to be 50 you go I'm really
sorry but my builder said it's gonna be
50 grand and we
about 15 yeah they can't be upset of you
because they were the one that guided
you on that in the first place yeah okay
this is a massive aggressive action yeah
and offers and viewings and all that but
then before you sign anything or before
you send any money
mm-hmm lots of wise professional counsel
yeah and due diligence that's it yeah
okay so in terms of company should I
already set up my company before the DfE
cuz so so time wise so I'm gonna be the
mature calendar so the DfE II do the
next one is and I could be vlogging the
DfE to I mean in Florida vlog it man
sorry
you need to consent to film which I'll
give you right now yeah okay thank you
so I'm literally like my tour ends on
Tuesday the 17th of September and
literally 18th
it's the DfE so so I could be the only
thing that I would general said you want
to be busy yourself yes send up a
company and stuff a personnel plan
account to do that but less human but
can do not like online and online but
the thing is it might cost you like 150
pounds again account to do it and then
it's done properly I would just pay
someone to do it yeah and I can just you
have accountants in your little
accountants yeah yeah I can give you my
counts detail now like yeah it's not
it's not it's very simple
yeah okay sort of after that have that
okay so set up my company and the main
goal is to just block everything and
just go full force yeah I might have so
many deals my mistakes on camera and
then and then and then embrace the the
yeah yeah yeah and just say is this
gonna be a year of failing my way to
success
yeah no I I love that are so good okay
set up company so okay yeah okay so so
to sum it up so um the main goal is to
do as many property deals using as many
strategies as possible in 12 months and
then it says what the best strategy is
and why yes and then I will document
everything and the goal is to build my
audience my audience and also to inspire
them and just document everything yeah
and then to do a big deal like a a crown
jewel yeah that's gonna stand out though
Claudius took this deal and then I have
the experience and knowledge to do
bigger deals and then off the back of my
brand and contacts I can then do bigger
deals yeah and that's when I got kick
cons get me to the to the Billy not not
the one okay now like you've got if I
just dump it into one big commerce you
could tell me hey Claudius just buy one
big commercial and it's like what you
might know around a month now forever
which is awesome but that's it and off
no audience no yeah yeah that's wrong
then you got it okay what's what's your
goal now in like the next few years
Nicole Margolin XP it's just to create
as many life-changing stories as
possible mmm i want i wanna i want to
create big people
none of it not just big numbers the
crash course I can set a thousand
tickets they're crossed across every
week I've proved that I can get a big
number
yeah I could be saying I want to get
10,000 no no no I don't want to create
big numbers I want to create big people
I don't want to document that I know I
won
I want ultimately you know when I'm when
I work at my funeral I want there to be
thousands of people there saying look
how many lives were changed you know
yeah yeah yeah that's and impact impact
people always want to create stories and
then tell stories yeah so you I'd like
you to be part of my story
yeah and then people will watch your
channel and then they'll go on to be
successful no do deals but then it will
link back to me because of the rippling
effect yeah gentlemen yeah just because
that makes me feel fulfilled yeah
not because I'm gonna need go trip or
because I even want money but because I
just I just wanna I just I just want to
create history yeah no that's awesome do
you have which also at some point invest
like overseas I get in America and
multi-family or want to get me to do
some irony which I'm open to but not in
the I love the UK and I think the yeah
as a massive massively I mean we're
after Germany we're the richest country
in Europe Germany's richer than in the
UK you know that yeah but we'll be yeah
yeah so so you yeah that's how do we
sent I'd like to see UK number one yeah
you know I love I love the UK yeah I
love and I want to be you know I want to
be a champion for UK entrepreneurship as
well yeah yeah and so when I focused so
much on property now to what degree do i
balance that with like my current
scootering and like my other youtube
channel how do you can answer that it's
like with me I've got my property
training business then I've got my
property buying business uh-huh and for
me I just I just do both flight as much
as I can
mm-hmm oh I can do everybody set targets
as well sent to you about what target
what's my target up for me it's just
about I just do all I can and I know
that I'm not going to stop understood if
I set a target for 20 if the hit 20 I'm
still gonna want more anyway I'm not
gonna go hit my target with axe I'm just
going to just push it push the airport
you know so you want a goal that's
that's like you want to be able to be a
billionaire because it's such a high
target you can athlete by the time you
get there you're gonna have become it's
not about being a billion it's about
becoming someone that can have a billion
literally I have this written dance and
mother thing that makes me so excited
about this is the the growth journey
yeah after growth and it's like the
person you have to become yeah and to
get to there it just shows like how much
you've grown as a person
yeah and how much value yeah like it's
because money is like you said it's a
byproduct just a result a result of
creating value yeah so if you're a
billionaire it's you've created value
you're gonna you're gonna have to touch
a billion people to be a billionaire
yeah any huge was going to be a good
vehicles do that yeah for sure that's
awesome
[Music]
you